football has a funny way of keeping
people humble I don't even think the
Dallas Cowboys could survive if we drop
three straight losses you might Parson I
mean damn you shot from deep and you
scored let's go let's go this show is to
give you the real deal spill about
what's going on in League the truth we
about that
life yo welcome back to the edge with
your boy Michael Parsons live in your
Bleacher Report app big one yesterday
right around the corner from the Trad
line trade deadline so let's get right
into it y'all know it was a spicy one
big one over the Rams and I got a big
Jersey up there right now y' see it
right there from the game yesterday my
man Aaron Donald the greatest Defensive
Player of our generation without a doubt
he even had two big sacks yesterday I
was admiring his game saw some big
matchups with Tyler Smith and Zack
Martin but at the end of the day that
guy right there man he's truly inspiring
um man he just does it right bro and man
I man when he go when he goes the game
won't be the same we going to miss him
um because that is a true legend and
that just completed my week and
everything because I just got Aaron Don
one of the greatest ever of this game
and without a doubt a Hall of Famer so
um that's Aaron Don that's how I feel
about that man right there um if you
didn't shoot see my costume I had to
show up as a lion and I even got this
cool custom chain too because the Lion's
always hungry y' know it is me rubbing
the stomach
um something cool shout out to my man
Christian Johnson with GLD does it big
for me every time bro um really
appreciate you love your brother um that
I think that might have been so that was
my first time I switched it up like the
last two years of my life I always been
like a Spider-Man because my son loves
Spider-Man and things like that um but
now we're into these animals and he
loves black panther and now he loves the
lion he's like I'm little lion he says
I'm the little lion I'm trying to wait
till I become big lion um but my
favorite costume yesterday I'm must say
it was the charge from the guy with the
Chargers game um who did the Above the
Rim costume um that was pretty dope and
that was hilarious bro I laugh like that
was you know trying to play like my man
from the uh Above the Rim so I thought
that was pretty dope my Cubs was also at
the game yesterday um I actually do
think I play better with my son's there
when my son's there because I played a
good game against Jets I had a good game
yesterday when my son's there when my
son's there it just hits different for
me bro I don't know if any of y'all like
know like but when my son's at the game
I feel like I got to go off like he's
looking up to me like he I feel like
he's counting everything I'm doing like
he's like good game dad like I don't
know he just gets so excited he's like I
want to be just like you like it just
means more when he's there like I don't
know I love that dude bro like y'all
don't even understand he's so happy to
be there and and enjoy the experience so
uh I always love it you know anytime
he's in town he comes to the game it
makes my game experience so much better
so I I would definitely say I play
better with him there so that means we
need to get him to every game because I
gotta play with that chip on my shoulder
he's my reason why he gives me
everything my inspiration and I love
that dude uh but let's get right into it
our big one over the rims and we're the
first team since 2007 with a defensive
TD a block Punt and a defensive safety
in the first half of a game first I want
to say this right we blocked a punt
against the r last year I believe and uh
I we had a defensive touchdown with them
last year especially because DW scooped
it up so I just feel like with them I
feel like we kind of got their number on
special teams and defense right now um
nothing towards R fans but we've been
kind of after them great match up they
always play us really well um and also
prayers up for Stafford because
obviously he dealt with that injury
wasn't able to complete the second half
but therefore we made that adjustment
saying we going to create our identity
of who we want to be coming out the by
we obviously we had two tough losses
before the by- we in the first six games
and we just said who we going to be
because we all know November football
really means the most um it it it goes
above and beyond November December is
where the Champions is made and this is
when the heat of the season starts K uh
heating up this lets us know who's going
to be in the playoff push where we're at
and things like that so you know that's
kind of who we are and we got a big one
coming up this week and we're going to
get into that a little bit later and
want to give a big shout out to my dog
Don Bland got his fourth interception of
the season and third pick six and I just
want to say this right Bland came in
last year somewhere like me uh but later
round pick um and he just came in with a
chip on his shoulder um obviously you
look at this crazy stat he has more
touchdowns than these top receivers in
the league who's GNA make a lot of money
Devonte Smith you could say he's a wide
receiver one t Higgins also Tyler
Lockett jayen wild all great players
Even Calvin really what he's doing over
over there in uh in Jacksonville right
now but this man has been playing lights
out truly special and he has answered
the call every time we needed him to
step up and when I say that is last year
when Jordan Lewis went down he answered
the call he people don't want to talk
about it but he needs to be talked about
more he had five picks last year as a
rookie you know he W you know I think
the only person that was above him was
Tariq Wen but five picks in his first
year and that was coming back this year
saying Trayvon Di go down and now he
stepped up and now he's back outside
he's an interchangeable piece a key
Dynamic piece to this defense I mean he
stepped up in every way when we need him
each year so big salute to you DB uh
keep going brother I'm proud to see your
growth always proud of you you should
have had another one I'm not gonna get
on you too much about that but you know
what I'm talking about um Dak finish 25
for 31 304 yards for TDS and that's just
my quarterback and you know obviously
when he starting that thing to CD lamb
12 receptions 158 yards in two TDS
special things goingon to happen uh I
truly believe this is what CD lamb and
Dak Prescott is capable of uh CD lamb is
a special talent that we're not talking
about because he hasn't been getting 12
receptions I think he can continue this
streak just like AJ Brown and we'll get
into him a little bit later of this type
of high intense uh and if you saw he set
records for the most and under 56 games
I was watch watching the screen he he
broke almost every record you know over
4,000 yards in the uh 56 games of f um
touchdown passes receptions over 300
receptions this guy iseal when the ball
gets his hand you go back to his OU tape
he just knows how to make it happen and
I think this is what cidd is capable of
when he gets those targets he's a
special talent he needs to be treated
like one um I think they are
establishing themselves as Elite QB wide
receiver Duo this is CD's second game in
a row over 125 when he's received seven
or more targets so obviously they're
turning the right direction keep giving
him the ball keep feeding him keep our
guy going cuz CD special and he need to
be treated like that same way as AJ
Brown Jamar Chase and guys like that
they need their targets they got to get
them in Rhythm that's the only way this
offense will get going that's the only
way we'll get going as a whole team is
seeing these guys establish themselves
saying I'm not here to play games and
it's going to be a great match of the
watch CD versus Bradberry and slay this
week obviously two great Corners um but
I was you know what I'm saying I always
got to take my guy CD L love him uh
that's my dog and I know he's made of he
got that dog in his chest Man Simple
like that on the other side was a tough
day for QB's injuries running League
including Matthew Stafford and my guy
Kirk Cousins uh many of you may not know
but Kurt Cousins is my guy and I'm
saying that not as we have such a close
relationship but after watching that QB
show of who Kurt Cousins is man if you
know what he puts into the game and how
he goes out there performing and things
he goes through the adversity how how
people look upon him and how tough that
dude really is I truly was inspired by
Kirt cousins in that documentary it
truly show light on the person he is the
type of player he is and how he
represents the National Football League
so prayers up to Kurt Cousins uh let's
give him a moment of
silence because it was truly devastating
uh what had happened to him and I know
he'll speed back I hope we see Kurt back
on that field because um that guy right
there is special and uh we hate to see
that happen for them and especially that
was also a big win for the Vikings I
don't know if anyone saw but you know
when he was getting carded off the field
he did not bow his head he clapped for
his teammates he still supported
everyone that's the type of guy Kurt is
I think it's always bigger than a game
of football uh for him it's always about
others it's always about you know his
teammates and making sure they stand up
high and they're not losing faith and uh
God loving fairing man that he is you
see it on him and it bleeds through him
so I I love to see that um I just saw
you know another a quote you know
actually we're not we're not even gonna
get into this because the media would be
media you know that y'all y'all continue
to say we haven't established a a good
opponent um but it's okay you know it's
it's the National Football League I
don't believe any team is bad injuries
happen you know um people didn't say
this when we lost our quarterback in
week one um of last year when Dak lost a
uh when Dak had uh fell out against the
bay herder's hand and we didn't have him
until after we played the Eagles at home
um and we had to win games without our
quarterback so at the end of day we
can't solely base everything off of
quarterback and injuries it's football
we got to play through them at the end
of the day so I don't consider injuries
an excuse of why we lose we just didn't
execute we got outplayed play and simple
as that um so you know when people
always use injuries and other things
like that man injuries happen it's
football it's a rough sport it's
something that we hate to see but
regardless we're seeing it more and more
so it at the end of day we got to stop
using injuries and things like that as
excuses at the end of day it's a
National Football League you got line up
for 60 minutes and play football at the
end of day that's what it's all about
and that's all it should ever be about
it should be about football and how are
you executing versus is not executing
and that and it's simple right there and
I wanted to give my dog of the week uh I
want to give him a big uh and he needs a
big highlight because he battled
injuries the last few years and you know
um he's not getting the credit he
deserves and that's denil Hunter I think
he should be in a race for a defensive
play of the year he he's he's leading
the league in sacks with 10 uh he had a
sack two Force fbls against the Packers
I think he's should get more media
attention um I should have talked about
him sooner when he was tied with TJ Watt
and that's on me I take full
accountability for that but denil hunter
needs more he's battled injuries the
last I think last year was his Peck uh
the year before that it it was his
shoulder uh something something Sil
something crazy like that uh but now
that he's healthy and he took the pay
cut he took the pay cut and proved that
he is what he is and he probably get a
bigger deal than this cuz he's on dog
time he's on demon time so congrat
ulations to den Hunter I mean keep going
uh we love to see it keep grinding it's
truly inspiring um when you thought that
they were rebuilding when they got rid
of Eric Hendricks when they got rid of
uh zidus Smith and they got rid of a
couple other vet guys they weren't
rebuilding they had their core and denil
Hunter is a part of that core and he's
showing light why he's here and why he's
still dominant and why Minnesota
decideed to keep him so we love to see
that another guy I would say my dog of
the week and I'm G give and I'm I'm G
give two dogs of the week for offense
because two special dudes broke records
and the first dog of the week is Tyreek
Hill this St is crazy the first player
in the history of the NFL to have a thou
actually not he's one of three but in
the last 62 years right um to have a
thousand uh thousand reception yards in
the first eight games of the Season
Tyreek Hill please slow down we see you
in December I need you to slow down
because you might be breaking Calvin
Johnson's record by then which is AB
Surly it's insane to think about you
know you give him another eight games
he's beating the record already he's on
Pace to do something that the league has
never seen before him and Tu are doing
something special down there in Miami I
mean it it's just truly special and I I
tip my cap brother I really tip my cap
what you're doing right now is a bigger
than the league so congratulations to
Tyreek Hill my second do a week and we
see him this week and that's AJ Brown
when we'll get more into him I mean six
straight games were over 125 yards man
like we we got to find a way to slow him
down but man that that's another dog of
the week uh I actually saw his oneand
catch in the in the end zone uh he's
trolling he's truly strong he's truly
Unstoppable and right now uh Tyreek Hill
and AJ gota be one and two punch however
you want to do of best wide receivers in
the league um I think he's truly shown
what he's capable of AJ he's on a
different level right now I mean it it
it's special what they're doing right
there
uh so congratulations those are my two
dogs of the week and simple as
that uh another big topic that uh some
people are talking about may not be
talking about it the 49ers have lost
three straight games uh since they lost
to us I mean since they beat us what I
would say is right it it's not so much
as it's pry because a lot of people are
saying it's py um and things like that
right it's
just you know and and I don't want to
anger nobody body and I don't want to
trigger anything but when things like
this happen right and and it's always
easy to blame a quarterback because when
they were winning it was always P's the
greatest Mr Irrelevant is this this that
and the other and it's always a rise and
a fall in NFL right at at one point
you're always gonna be on top of the
mountain right Dak Prescott was on top
of the mountain and soon as he had a
couple bad games it was like oh we'll
bring him back down here you know
football has a funny way of
keeping people humble right when people
want to go on Rants and they think
they're bigger than the game and they
think they're just better than everyone
and they feel like they don't have to do
more you know tough things happen and
I'm not saying this is a example for San
Francisco but you know everyone has to
deal with these things in NFL versus his
injuries versus his adversity and things
like that because losing three straight
and you would be considered a top five
NFL team including the talent that you
have
is very diff difficult to grasp I mean I
don't even think the Dallas Cowboys
could survive if we drop three straight
three straight losses right so I just
think San Francisco had a turn it around
uh they're battling adversity I think
not having Trent Williams and Debo is
really affecting the offense uh two
crucial pieces without a doubt um the
protection of pery has been down um but
also these are things that we haven't
seen from py yet though we haven't seen
pie play from behind I don't think you
know it's tough to put yourself in these
situations when you haven't been there I
think San Francisco's defense has done a
great job of creating turnovers uh
letting the 49ers run the ball uh
dinging dunk uh not having to really put
per in a situation where he has to drop
back where he has to make the quick
decisive read when he has to push down
the field he really hasn't been in no
situations um especially because they
like I said their defense has always
played strong uh and it's always good
and I mean it's and your guys may say oh
well he played you know the first halfs
or whatever but when you have the lead
or the scores tied it's a different game
of football when you're in a must Havoc
situation when you're in a must score
situation those situations where he
really hasn't had the face um and we
thought we would see it in the playoff
game last year against the Eagles but he
didn't still have he didn't have a
chance to face that because his injury
so I think he's just Growing Experience
you know it comes with a lot of
experience um I definitely think the
49ers were bounce back they're a great
team uh without a doubt I don't think uh
WEA we should bury them for their three
straight losses um because I do think
Kyle Shanahan's a great coach I do think
they have great things they have great
players and I don't think Nick Bosa and
Fred Warner will keep allowing this I
think guys would step up I think uh big
plays will be made um so let's not let's
not uh let's not get too worried about
them necessarily I do think it's
something that you know it's the NFL the
NFL will find a funny way of humbling
you um and that's just reality um I
think the 49ers humbled us and I just
think you know life humbled them and and
it goes like that sometimes and and and
it goes for a lot of people just like uh
the Chiefs you know people came up here
and they got mad at me because I said
that uh about they only were limited to
uh Patrick and Mahomes who else would
you go outside of well we saw Mahomes
sick and had the flu
um and it wasn't the same person
so it's it's truth to this I know a lot
of people don't want to hear it but like
outside of Travis and uh Patrick if
Patrick can be who he is and I don't
think no one's on the caliber of Patrick
Mahomes I think he's going to be the
greatest quarterback to ever play the
game of of football in the NFL he's
going to break every record I think he's
going to do incredible things in the NFL
and he's able to work with les he's able
to uh because of how gifted and how
special he is but at the end of the day
you need more you you got to be more
than that um and you know and I think
Denver had a big win this week uh over
the Chiefs um and they had a long streak
of beating Denver I think Denver's
changing things around they bet on their
young guys and the things are turning
around for them uh their defense is
showing up they had played a great
defensive game against the Chiefs so uh
this is special to see out of them uh
they got two wins in a row Russell
Wilson's playing great football uh a lot
of people blame their loss but if you
look at what's going on uh Russell
Wilson's in top five categories uh you
know in QB's uh stats statistical stats
uh with Shawn Payton so I mean they're
playing good football in Denver uh
they're changing things around it'll be
very interesting to see what they do in
this uh November and December
push uh secondly Jo Play Joe burrow
played like he's fully healthy against
uh yesterday against the 49ers and we'll
just continue that 28 uh 28 for 32 20
283 yards three TDS um and I remember
when people said a lot about them when
they dropped two three games oh what's
going on with burrow what's going on
with them and now they're on the rooll
the league is funny man you gotta build
off that like I said there's no
Champions that hasn't been Championship
tested right uh they're there're like
you got to get Battle tested Joe burrow
battle early adversity I said once he
got his calf right I said once he got
grooving uh we'll see the same Joe
burrow like I said this is the National
Football League you against the best
players and sometimes you're not going
to be 100 and you're not going to be at
your best in the best moments that you
may want to and that's just the
competitors but you're going against the
best competitors in the world the top 1%
and sometimes people tend to forget that
so Joe Bro is back on track like I
thought he would I didn't I knew Joe bur
would get back you could look at from
his rookie year to his second year his
third year it's who he is he's Mr he's
Joe Ice come on man like y y'all can't
think he'll stay down forever I'm glad
to see him back on track I'm glad the
people stop putting dirt on his name
because that's the Joe burrow we seen in
the playoffs that's the Joe burrow that
went to the Super Bowl and I had chance
that went to the Super Bowl so I'm glad
to see that um you know and you know
what does this say about the Bengals I
it just goes to show you that anything
can happen right you know the Bengals
was going against that big 49ers defense
who we all know has a top five defense
in the league um and they went out there
and put 37 did anyone have you know the
Bengals putting up 37 on them no but but
they're loaded with Talent they got all
these guys that can get open Jamar Chase
going over for 100 that's what you
that's just the competition that you're
facing week and week out you just really
never know um they just and it just
turns the uh wheel like that sometimes
well burrow fully healthy uh where does
that rank them among top teams in the
league uh you have to put them in the
top seven uh without a doubt um you can
argue it however you want to do it but
their offense and their defense they
might not have the big name star s that
you know the 49ers have or the D Cowboys
have or the Jets have but Sam hubber
Trey Henderson uh Germaine Pratt uh my
guy joe side they play balls out like
they play non-stop they pay above the
2.3 they play how the game should be
played and they play aggressive they
play they play downhill uh Logan Wilson
they play the game the right way their
defense knows how to jail they know how
to come together they're a hard fought
team and I'm G just put like that I
they're the one of the most better
well-rounded teams in the National
Football League so their top seven team
however you want to rank it uh just not
just bordering that fifth six however
you want to rank it uh with like that so
I definitely think they're a top seven
football
team uh the Chiefs lost to the Broncos
on Sunday uh after Patrick Mahomes had
the flu
um you know and and you know it's tough
sometimes you want to go out there and
have a a flu game obviously Patrick
don't want to let his team down he knows
how much they need him um so I don't say
nothing about Patrick you know it's
nothing against uh him you know I play
the game with the flu and not play my
best it it just happens uh this this
just do change who Patrick is and his
identity he will still next week when
he's not sick he'll probably you
know you know be be as great as he can
be and you know that was their first win
uh the Broncos first win of the Chiefs
2015 uh so that's a great win for the
Broncos and Shawn Payton uh I love to
see that uh keep going Broncos Nation
keep changing this season around uh and
I we can't wait to see how this uh
November push hit again and we're gonna
get into this one because I already
defended Zack Wilson all year and he
came up clutch on Sunday a lot of people
saying that Juds spotted the ball
themselves to set the game time field
goal cuz this was big and and I'm going
be honest with you when I first saw it I
didn't agree with this either I I feel
like that was one of the quicker ways
the refs uh spotted the ball the refs
did touch the ball but you can argue it
because I remember my rookie year the
ref fully had to grab the ball and put
it in place himself uh so that was one
thing that I thought was a little shaky
especially uh because I seen it
personally where the ref made sure we
didn't have enough time um but it is
with ref did touch the ball uh he and
you see he kind of dabbed at it but it
is it is I feel like they shouldn't have
been put in a situation the Giants have
to finish that game they got to get off
the field uh but what does this tell you
about Zack Wilson I tell you one thing
it tells you that he got guts he has
that he has that fire him he has that
desire to win he Tes I'm not giving up
since that incident Zack Wilson has went
on a streak of wins uh the Jets are now
winning games they're looking good and
if we all saw Aaron Rogers is now
dropping back so we potentially might
see Aaron Rogers come January because we
seem can't akr come back uh we seen cam
Acres come back from uh KY six months
early did jesser now have three straight
wins is looking very special for them if
they could get Rogers back uh you know
he went to the great Dr La Char out of
La so it this thing might have a chance
for the Jets Jets Nation I wouldn't give
up this looks very special um and as
long as Zach Wilson's keep getting
better and and he's under the influence
of Aaron Rogers what I knew and I knew
would help him because vet leadership is
so important especially to a Young
quarterback uh it's going to get Zack
Wilson going to be a great backup for
when uh Aaron Rogers comes back or even
if Zack Wilson has to make this push
that defense is still great they still
have great weapons and they are looking
very good uh so I love to see that out
of Zack Wilson and keep proving them
wrong Zack I know a lot of people said
you were trash and they couldn't you
couldn't do nothing with that team hey
um so just keep going just keep going
Zack I know uh what you're capable of um
and and that's what it is and another QB
that shined is Will Levis uh in place of
Ryan tanah Hill this week uh real will
you always know is we are uh he was a
Penn State guy before he transferred uh
to Kentucky but 19 for 29 238 yards four
TS and a win that's a coming out party
if you ask me uh will always had a
special talent uh great arm strength you
saw dehop uh with three TDS welome back
dehop but that's always great to see uh
it it questions of what what will the
Titans do um I think with Will Levis I
mean I would think he still need more
you would have loved to see will Levis
do this earli in season because maybe
they keep will L and trade you know her
uh Ryan tanah Hill to the Vikings who
now need a quarterback especially a vet
quarterback uh you never know how that
could have looked or what this trade
deadline could look like uh by the end
of NE uh this week
um but let's listen to DeAndre Hopkins
after his 3 TD
game
[Music]
[Applause]
one they roll me off I feel
like yeah I I definitely think dehop is
still an elite receiver I think he hav't
get the targets or the looks or the
scheme to uh get him open uh Kyler was
injured in Arizona he came into a system
where he felt like he can help carry
this team and will lens made sure he got
the ball he put in his best receiver's
hands and great things happen when you
trust your best receiver uh I do think
dehop still has a chance he's dominated
this league for a very long time uh keep
giving him a chance uh I think this
could be a great I would love to see
what they do after this how they
expanded uh so dehop we looking hey we
Ain write you off yet keep proving us
keep proving people wrong uh because you
sh why you deserve to be in this league
and I love to see
it um like I mentioned beginning of the
show the trade deadline is tomorrow uh
what team should go all in for all in
before trade dayline uh at this
point if if you if you really want to
look at
it I I think teams that's on a cusp uh I
would love to see I obviously the Giants
already did a trade Seahawks made a huge
trade I thought that was important uh
cuz they wanted more Rush interior rush
and things like that uh a team that I
feel like you know I
think I think we could make a trade the
Cowboys could make a trade uh to get
more death at o line um or you know
death at corner or you know dline uh you
can't get enough or even linebacker uh
Missing Vander right now uh it's truly
but Mars Bell is truly stepping up I
would love to
see uh I want to see what the Titans do
with Derrik Henry uh I I think the
Ravens could use a trade right now go
get them a running back more running
back death uh I also think the Chiefs
could use a trade go get you uh a medium
Cher receiver or Elite receiver uh to go
with Travis Kelce uh and I and I think
those two teams could really benefit uh
from the
trades um Grady Jared out for the season
become a torn ACL prayers up to Grady
Jared um how bad do the Falcons need
montz sweat I think they need him bad uh
but at this point after Los Grady Jared
losing your interior piece um it what's
the rush now you know you lose that guy
which you would hope would make your
dline better montz and Grady uh inside
and outside Duo that could have been
special uh so I think they don't need
them right now I I mean you could trade
for him and say hey finish off the year
but you know in the future this could be
a dynamic duo um but right now they
truly might be in tank mode uh for the
Falcons uh especially after losing
against the tit Titans I mean it it's
hard to recover from this league when
you start the record you are right now
um so they could probably use all the
draft Capital they could get and they
need Death at a lot of positions so uh
it it'll be very interesting to see what
happens but at the end of the day next
week we got a huge matchup against the
Eagles uh last week I said they were the
best team in the NFL do I still believe
that it's true uh and yeah I do uh
regardless of what what I think or what
I say or you know I'm not a person that
lives in denial uh I know what's out
there I see what's in front of me I see
uh what's out there I don't think the
Eagles play their best football at all
yet um I think you know they know
they're so good they could beat a lot of
teams off of talent um they have the
most talented roster in the NFL without
a doubt I I don't care how you match it
up um you've seen how they matched up
against the Miami Dolphins who has a
certain amount of talent they were
missing Jaylen Ramsey but I don't think
that made like a two jump of a
difference uh they got talent and at wi
receiver uh running back uh DBS I mean d
line I mean they just got crazy Talent
um you know so I still do believe
they're the best team better than day
you still got to go out there compete
and execute um how does this defense
prepare for the tou push we just got to
go out there and be out more physical um
did you see they fake one it's just
becoming more creative more inventive uh
and things like that so I
mean you can just say what you want I
mean I think they're very Dynamic team
um is very interesting to see uh and
Jaylen Herz he may not be playing his
best ball um and people would say it's
he the QB standard in NFL I think you
know when it comes to leadership and how
he prepares and what he puts into the
game yeah of course but when it comes to
QB I mean Patrick Mahomes is still the
best QB in the NFL and and it's just
like um but it's going to be a great
game uh I'm not giving them no Firepower
I just want to go out there line up and
have a great game Sunday night and may
the best man win um and see who comes
off to feel Victorious so uh let's get
it it's gonna be a great game Sunday
Dallas Cowboy Nation uh Eagles one of
the biggest rivalries in football Dallas
Cowboy Nation I need y'all to all stand
up be out there and Philadelphia is
going down in the City of Brotherly Love
come get it we need y'all we need to
make this a home game yall know how they
get it's going to be loud it's going to
be wild it's going to be crazy uh fans
all over so let's get right to it
Cowboys Nation I'mma see you Sunday
let's take some final questions from the
chat uh what do you think about Bill
signing lyard forette uh great uh I
think that's a great pickup for them uh
you know Leonard's a hard Runner
downhill maybe open some things up for
Josh Allen uh and also pair well with
James Cook I think James Cook is more
like a lightning running back a guy who
can you know jet out to the flat go for
the passes you know a passing back can
do it all um but now he can't carry the
low give some of that to Lenny uh and
keep James fresh uh World Series
prediction obviously I gota go with my
Texas Rangers uh game three tonight is
gonna be very fun I can't wait to watch
it I hope my Rangers pull it off and I
hope we finish them at home and Rangers
win big parade in
Texas uh the 49ers been losing since
they said the f Dallas Sho t-shirt k is
crazy ain't it yeah karma is always
crazy you know it's always uh
interesting to see how that stuff always
plays itself uh like I always say laugh
now cry later at the end day nobody has
ever won a championship in September
it's all won at the end of the season
and it's definitely won in February so
losing Early learn battle adversity and
just get better at the end of the day
you still got to play football um so um
all right take a purse as you will you
know they still gotta play football so I
hope they a forget that
factor I would rather have a three-game
losing streak now than in January and
definitely uh like I said it's not going
to change nothing for the N 49ers I
still think they're a great team I still
do still think they're doing great
things uh and I and when they do become
healthy and they do get everybody back
they're a menace they're they're they're
something not to be played with they're
a great team regardless uh and and
that's just the key you know I think
people tend to see people losing see
people failing and call them so quick to
say they're failures or they're not good
or they're so quick to panic people just
can't live in chaos when you're in this
profession and so you're so used to you
know things and adversity things going
bad and things you have to try them from
you learn to deal with these things you
learn to have to deal with them and live
with them uh and and that's all a part
of the game the game is ugly it's not
for everyone and you learn that so hey
all the teams out there keep going all
the players that's out there batt vers
injury keep going the game needs you
it's all a part of life it's all about
your story you know every story is not
perfect you're not going to see too many
16 olds and 17 olds it's just not
realistic it's so hard to win in NFL and
people don't realize that so I want to
say thank you for tuning in to the edge
with your boy Michael Parsons it's
always great to talk to y'all drop the
knowledge drop the hottest tea in the
NFL with y'all and let y'all know what's
up the truth the real honest opinion no
makeups no fake stories and no uh I
don't know my identity tals and that's
just the truth about it I appreciate
y'all love y'all uh can't wait to see
y'all next
week